multiplying fractions is actually
really easy sort of it's only easy
for two of the three kinds of fractions
right
uh just leave it there that's fine uh
what are the three kinds of fractions do
you remember what they are
yeah no mix new rules that's the first
one somebody give
someone give me another one yeah liam
improper fractions and obviously because
these are improper the last one is for
one
proper fraction it's good now four
two of them namely this one and this one
multiplication and fractions is super
easy in fact it's probably easier than
adding them okay
but what we've got over here is mixed
numerals now being that this
is harder and i'll show you why in a
second the strategy we're going to take
is we're going to turn this into one of
these and then it's simple
okay so watch with me first what i'm
going to do is show you
a common way to approach this which
isn't right but it's just as important
to look at ways
not to do something than to know the
ways to do it okay because then you know
what to avoid and common mistakes
a lot of people make them so we want to
watch out for them now
one of the ways i've seen a lot of you
do is say well i've got this
times this right i don't really know how
to do that so i'll separate them out
i'll do the whole numbers first i'll go
one times one
and that's one and then i've got a half
and a half so i'll go a half
times a half and because that's a proper
fraction it's easy to multiply
half of a half is a quarter
right so you're like i've got one times
one here i've got half times half here
i should put them together and you get
one plus a quarter that's one and a
quarter okay
now you should be suspicious of this
right this is not the right way to go
though it does seem like it makes sense
the way you can know even before knowing
what is the right way to do it the way
you can know this is actually not right
is because
if you multiply something by one and a
half right like say 10
times one and a half does the number 10
does it get bigger or does it get
smaller it gets bigger it'll get 50
bigger one and a half okay but one and a
quarter
is smaller than what we started with
it's smaller than both of these right
so one and a quarter can't possibly be
the right answer so therefore
how do we do it okay well what i'm going
to do as i said before
i'm going to convert i'm going from a
mixed numeral into an improper fraction
and then i can just multiply across so
let's watch
one and a half it's nice that they give
us the same number because once we do
one we've got both of them
what's one and a half as an improper
fraction yeah maybe
three and two perfect and the way you
can see that right
is if i split this back up into a two
and a one
two plus one over two your two over two
is your one out the front and you're one
over two is the
half there you go three over two and
it's the same fraction again okay so
now that it's improper fraction it's
really easy let me just um rather than
put down the answer i'll show you what's
the what's going on in my head
i want to multiply the numerators and
multiply
the denominators they turn into one
fraction okay
3 times 3 of course is 9 and 2 times 2
is
4. now that is the correct answer but b
that they gave it to us as a mixed
numeral
we should probably give it back as a
mixture rule as well
so some of you will be able to convert
this directly to a mixed numeral which
is great
for those of you who maybe can't see it
straight away what
intermediate line could i put in here to
help me work out what mixed new rule is
equivalent to
what can i do
yeah good you do nine divided by four
right
you get how many fours fit into nine
two so i'm going to get a two out the
front okay but there's a remainder isn't
it what's left over
there's one because two times four is
eight right so that remainder of one
becomes the fraction there there you go
oh thank you my ocd self is happy now
okay great there you go
so that's fine that's the way you do it
some of you as well might
write it like this eight plus one over
four
because a plus one is nine eight over
four is two it's exactly the same thing
okay but the important thing is you just
show this working i know you want to go
straight from
here to here or even not even write this
down
just write down the answer the problem
with that is
uh both in your own work and an exam is
if
something is wrong something up here
gets confused and you get this wrong
if none of this is shown if all i see is
just that
right then i don't know where it's come
from i don't know if you just
guessed i don't know if you really
understand what's going on okay whereas
you can see
what's happening and how i've gotten the
answer okay
does anyone clarify anything that's on
the board there does it make sense
um i'm gonna do the next one you're
gonna tell me what to do though
okay so let's do the next one which is
h 2 and 2 7.
what am i going to do first i need to do
a
conversion right yeah
good okay so let's do the two episodes
elena do you reckon you could convert
that into an improper fraction for me
well done okay so if you didn't see that
straight away the 16 comes from
seven times two which is fourteen plus
two
so it sort of goes around if you
remember me doing that diagram
right so 16 is seven good three and a
half
oh improper fraction who could do it
yeah
this is a good example to follow up with
because
we could multiply across but you've seen
before we want to avoid big numbers
right so rather than 16 times 7 and 7
times
2 i'm going to notice i can cancel right
if there's a 7 on the top and a 7 on the
bottom i can get rid of
both of them right this guy and this guy
they will vanish so that's going to be
16 on 2 which of course is
eight there you go and you don't need to
do any more conversions
that's it okay